So we've been talking quite a bit about the
Catholic Church, considering some, I guess
what we would call progressive, or at least
leftward reform is within its organization.
And I thought for today's classic interview,
we'd go back to a very odd interview I did
back in 2014 with a guy named James White,
sort of quirky anti gay pastor. Uh, and I
thought we could all sort of reflect on how
much society would benefit from reforming
some of the wackiness out of established religion.
So let's get right to it. I'm joined today
by James White. He is a current UCC pastor
and he is located in the gold tree, Oklahoma
church. So let's start first. James, what
is the UCC, what denomination is that?
So United Church of Christ is a combination
of the merger took place in the early sixties
between the Evangelical Reform Church, Congregational
Christian Church. Uh, they're very liberal
and, um, our partners, um, so to speak with
the disciples of Christ, uh, if you're ordained
to one, you can be a minister and the other
and vice versa. Um, it seems here lately,
a lot of the church growth has come because
of [inaudible],
uh, uh,
the MCC churches that left the metropolitan
community church and joined the UCC.
Uh, but,
okay, so what we'll let, let's let that give
it tells us what it is, but I w I don't, I
want to get right into kind of your situation.
So you're going to be stepping down as pastor
of the Goltry Oklahoma UCC church. And the
issue you have a problem with is same sex
marriage. So outline what is the his position
and what is your position that is so different
that it's causing you to resign?
Well, actually the local level, they agree
with me. Um, but uh, the problem is that they
don't want to leave the denomination. They're
great people.
But so I think did, so let me reframe it because
I want to walk people through it. Uh, churches
in the UCC recognize and can solemn Nuys same
sex marriage. And that's what you disagree
with. Right? I just want to be totally explicit
so our audience knows what we're talking about.
Absolutely. I, I first became a part of the
UCC back in 2008 and was driving down to Oklahoma
City. I was actually a part of a church that's
mostly gay and lesbian for a while. And then
once I graduated seminary, um, I had to find
a preaching position.
Um, but
the more I, the more I personal study I did
on my own, uh, the more I realized that what
I was what I had been taught, uh, in seminary
and what I learned through the denomination
wasn't accurate.
So explain that. So what, what is your view
of same sex marriage?
I, um, I define marriage is between a man
or woman, uh, that comes, uh, from the Bible.
Uh, what I have over dealing with people through
in the denomination is that the more that
they value experience over scripture, the
more liberal they are. And the more that they
value the Bible over experience than the more
conservative they tend to be.
Now, as someone who has studied this and is
a, a student of s of knowledge, so to speak,
um, wouldn't it tell you that if people base
their lives and their points of views more
on their experience and their thinking than
on what a book purportedly written by God
tells them, maybe that's more what we should
be listening to. Maybe experience and logic.
Tell us more about how we should treat gay
and lesbian couples. Then a book clearly written
by humans, but supposedly written by God tells
us maybe, maybe we could learn from that.
Well, let me make one thing clear. And this
is probably where some conservatives would
disagree with me on, is that I don't think
of this as being in salvation. I think there
are people who are, uh, gay and lesbian who
are genuinely saved. That's, I will see on
who I will see on the other side. Okay. And,
and the thing about, like, my experience with
Cathedral hope is that these people are genuinely
wanting to do the right thing. Uh, they do
reach out to people at the gay pride event
and there are thousands of people there. And
it was really disheartening, you know, it
was like the Sunday night service after that
weekend would take place and you might have
three or four new people show up when you
literally handed out thousands of flyers and
buttons and you had people participate in
this parade either on Friday or Saturday and
the, and then very few people showed up. So
yeah, that can be tough, but okay.
My mission to the salvation of the people
of Cathedral of hope. Right?
Yeah. And I'm not either, but, but salvation
aside, just for a second, it sounds like your
opposition to gay marriage, lesbian marriage
is primarily bible-based. In other words,
you didn't mention one, uh, anti-gay argument,
which is it's not natural. You didn't mention
the, it doesn't lead to reproduction. You
didn't mention, well, it's illegal redefinition.
And I don't like that. Correct me if I'm wrong,
but your opposition is mostly Bible based,
is that right?
Well, I would say that. And here's the thing
that really kind of throws a red flag up for
me is that a lot of the people I spoke with,
uh, that are gay and lesbian, um, whenever
I would mention things like, uh, bigeminy
polygamy and, and other things, they never
really wanted to draw the line there. They
never really wanted to say, well, that stuff
is bad. Um, what I'm hearing now, uh, is the
idea of marriage equality for everybody. We'll
have to have some kind of limits because if
you don't, then, then, then what are you defining
marriage?
Well, that's interesting because, and again,
you and I are talking, we're not having a
legal discussion. Obviously religious texts
have no bearing at all on legal structure
in this country. Whether you agree with that
or not with me, we're, we're leaving that
out for this conversation. But let's address
it from the point of view of the Bible. The
Bible talks about men with multiple wives,
men with multiple wives and concubines, et
Cetera, et cetera. So is it not arbitrary
to say that because of the Bible you are against
gay marriage for example, although the Bible
talks about multiple wives, concubines, et
Cetera, it talks about stoning your, the,
the, your wife, if she's not a virgin on her
on the wedding day, et Cetera. Isn't it all
just kind of cherry picking?
Well, the thing about that is, I'm glad you
brought it up, is that you really can't find
one example of a healthy relationship where,
where somebody did have multiple wives. I
think, uh, the Bible mentions in First Corinthians
that we have the old test as an example for
us. And really if you think about it, could
you really have two, three, four wives and
love each one of them equally and the same?
And I don't think you can.
So let's use that. I like that. I like that
you're applying that question, which is let's
just think about this logically and say, can
you really be married to four people and love
them equally and have that type of relationship?
And you're thinking the answer is no. What
is it about a relationship between one man
and one woman? Uh, I'm sorry, between two
men or between two women where you couldn't
have the same type of love that you have in
a male female relationship applying just the
kind of casual logic test that you applied
just a second ago.
Well, to add some further to the design of
marriage, I think the thing that makes marriage
so great is that your, you're married to somebody
who thinks differently than you do by during
the last 13 plus years. Um, my wife has challenged
me, stretched me, uh, really your wife, I
will retched you. I would say, ah, well just
when I was, when I first got married I was
very selfish and very self centered and I
did not even realize how much. So during the
time we've been married, I've learned how
to care for others in a way that you know,
but James, what you're seeing, what you're
saying, James, if I may, you're going down
an incredibly misogynistic path, which is
suggesting that only women can teach men how
to care for others. You're also using very
anecdotal evidence, which as as a student
who, who is someone who, who is an educated
person, I'm sure you know that anecdotal evidence
is not really what we should talk about to,
to discuss broad policy or, or ideas. It seems
incredibly offensive to so many men to say
that women are what is needed to learn to
care about others.
Well, I think it goes two ways. I think there
are things that she's learned about life from
me as well. [inaudible] I'm contrasting that
to two men or two women because m m at least
in my opinion, it's a mirror image. You're,
you're with somebody who does think like you
do and isn't really going to challenge you
on certain things.
I just think that this is a very silly argument
though, James, because the idea that you think
the same as anyone else who is the same gender
as you and therefore you wouldn't learn from,
from marriage. I, I've, I've honestly, it's
an interest. It's, I'm interested in this
idea because I've never heard it before, but
it's not a very strong argument is it?
Uh, well we'll have to agree to disagree on
that one. Ah, I know, me personally, my life
is very fulfilling. Uh, and
now if you were attracted to men, if you were
born just being attracted to men, would you
not be fulfilled if you were able to marry
the man that you loved hypothetically? Right.
Would you, would you not find fulfillment
in that?
Yeah.
Hm. That's an interesting question. I probably
honestly, I don't know. I have to, I'm too,
it's so hard for you to imagine not being
straight because you were born straight. Correct.
Okay.
Um, yeah, I, I'm not going to completely dismiss
the science that I think you're referring
to, but I think there needs to be more done
as far as whether or not you can be born gay.
I think there needs to be more scientific
research.
Um, but, so Mike, my questions that I get
to say, did you ever decide James, you when
you were, I don't know, seven to say, okay,
well, right now I'm completely neutral between
being attracted to men or women. I think I'm
going to choose to be attracted to women.
You never had that revelation, did you?
Okay.
Uh, well most of my time, up until the age
of 10, I was either playing basketball, football,
or kickball. So
that's fair. Perfectly Fair. So at 10 is,
when is that when you made the decision you
could have gone either way, you could've been
in guys, you could've been into girls and
you said, well, I'm 10, I played enough kickball,
now I'm going to choose to be into women.
Is that how it went for you or did you at
some point just realize you're attracted to
women?
That's an interesting question. Who's the
actual girl I was attracted to probably sixth
grade. I knew a girl named Shannon who had
a failed their grade. And so she was a little
bit more, I'm sure I'll say physically mature
than some of the role models. And uh,
so you were attracted, you were attracted
to your classmates breasts, and that was a,
that was a physical reaction you had. You
never said, I'm going to decide today to like
my classmates breasts. That just happened.
Okay. I, I think I, I see that you're kind
of putting up some obstacles, but I think
the audience kind of gets where I'm going
with this. We are at a time. James, I wish
you the best of luck. I'm sorry that your
opposition to marriage equality is leaving
you to leave your position. I hope you find
a new position and I do. Thank you for joining.
Thank you so much. Have a great day.